I wonder if you could talk to us in a
bit more detail about security concerns
or otherwise how are you feeling about
it
well it's interesting that the president
has said he's here to keep the peace and
indeed that's what police officers have
been doing here day after day year after
year and this operation despite its
scale is no different uh clearly the
police are here in numbers uh overtly
you can see that and their job is to
protect life and protect property and
indeed keep the peace and to do that by
preventing crime and that includes
illegal demonstrations or anything that
might disrupt or distract from the from
the visit so what I can see is a it's a
very well thought out and planned
operation and that involves teams and
individuals on the ground all knowing
what their part to play is all about
I'm writing saying I think that you were
there when uh President Clinton visited
Northern Ireland how
different do you think the security will
be today than uh back in 97 when um 98
when he was there
well in one sense it will be very
similar in terms of planning for
contingencies and and as I said working
with the security services and indeed
alerting the public to the type of
operations so they understand what
police are doing but sadly uh the
optimism of the period just after the
Good Friday agreement has been replaced
with a degree of pessimism in the sense
that we have the dissident threat we've
had the attempted murder of the
detective Chief Inspector we've had the
pipe bombs found at the weekend so
clearly there is a an element that is
all too clear that there are those who
wish to carry on armed conflict or
around extremism so from that point of
view it is difficult there's also issues
around
brexit and of course the lack of a
working executive at the minute so in a
sense the atmosphere is different but in
terms of the police task it's very
similar
but it has not in my opinion created the
same amount of
involvement or optimism from the general
public there were Chrome crowds
yesterday to welcome the president when
he arrived in Belfast but it's
relatively relatively subdued compared
to what we saw in the late 90s
um take me back to the late 90s if you
would when you saw President Clinton
stepping off Air Force One and you knew
that hopefully it was going to be a
momentous few days there was a lot of
pressure on you
I'm sorry okay the line's slightly
difficult can you repeat the question I
most certainly can we are looking at the
moment that President Clinton stepped
off Air Force One as you said back in
the 1990s quarter of a century ago to be
met by uh Tony Blair waving to the
crowds there
um you knew well it was going to be a
momentous few days thankfully uh along
with him and momoland George Mitchell
and the like they managed to pull it off
you must have felt the pressure to keep
the president and others safe
yeah if I'm hearing a crackless in
relation to the presidential security
and of course that will be Paramount
um last time there was a lot of who had
to in fact I remember being at the the
steps of Air Force One when the
president in 1995 came down the steps
and uh as I said there's a great degree
of optimism but the the threat of some
disruption or indeed an attack on the
president who's all always a Target uh
is is Paramount so the Security
operation will be proportionate and
Justified but in the same sense
um the place now I suppose on a
different level of training and
expertise like any learning organization
so they'll have had to take into account
human rights issues the community impact
and of course officer safety so as you
can see from what happened at the
weekend officer safety is a priority for
police officers and those in command as
well so it's about a balanced operation
but at the same time clearly the
priority is to make sure the
presidential visit goes without any
disruption